alo alo Xin chào bạn
ờ ờ
ừ ừ
từ hôm nay thì như mình có thông báo thì
hôm nay mình sẽ tiếp tục à Chưa lộn chấm
nốt cho
những nhóm còn lại bữa hôm trước nó
không ạ
à Xong rồi à
những nhóm Hôm nay muốn mình chữa tất cả
review code nóng
Ừ thì bình luận nhé á
ở những chữa tính năng à
Ừ
tôi nốt lại có khá nhiều cái cần phải
làm
chỉ
cần phải trả lời cho các bạn thì
về vụ là Ờ hôm hôm nay điểm thì hôm nay
trở lại vì tôi muốn hả cậu cái kiểu cách
viết cốt nhắn nó tắt ở trong tfp để mà
kiểm tra MT kiểm tra Chồng nhá Nó là
kiểu như mà nó kiểm tra xem là nếu mà
nếu mà về bên trái trống thì sẽ lấy về
bên phải Và ngược lại là
ở đây nó sẽ kiểu trường hợp nào như thế
này ra xử ra do sử là nếu ở bên trái
trống ngay thì lấy về bên phải là sửa
test nha Chẳng
gì đấy
vì thế Đây đây là cách viết tắt để mặt
kiểm tra chấm nó có thể tương đương với
kiểu cô này như này anh luôn nè
Chưa mà giống như này chữa không
giống MC mà không ạ Và
A và cái này thậm chữa ra sự mạnh Đấy là
mảnh cổ dạng là không chụp key kia không
tồn tại thì nó sẽ không bảo lỗi là nó sẽ
mặc định này với phải đâu nhiên nữa giờ
sửa Nếu mà có giá trị như này thì đương
nhiên nó sẽ lấy về bên trái rồi nó sẽ
không lấy về bên phải nữa đấy Đây là
cách viết tắt thì thì bây giờ Làm thế
nào để tra được cái viết
ờ ờ tra cách viết tắt để mà cậu với với
từ ngôn ngữ nó sẽ có cách kiểu dạng là
cái viết tắt khác nhau chứ phải cái viết
tắt nào ngôn ngữ nào giống nào đó nghe
cái tắt thì sẽ dùng cho hè như thế này
và hôm nay tôi vừa tra xong sót hen
trách MTP như thế này thì nó sẽ người ta
sẽ gợi ý Kiểu mình sẽ dùng hỏi chấm 2
chấm như thế này Đấy là được Ok bạn
Ờ nhưng mà Ừ nhưng mà còn đấy cách viết
tắt và đôi khi ở mấy ông kiểu span ý tao
nhã
ở tp nó sẽ là gì
thì nó sẽ là kiểu dùng hỏi chấm hỏi chấm
xong rồi hai chấm như này nhưng mà
Ừ nếu Trang chở mày đúng
ở đây Cái này tôi thường anh dùng trong
ngoặc tròn kiểu như này nếu trong trường
hợp về đúng thì trường hợp này đúng ấy
thì mình sẽ lấy cái này không sẽ lời cái
này đây cái viết kiểu ít em
Ừ Giời Đúng Sai bằng bằng bằng nha Đúng
rồi xay không ạ ạ ạ
à còn Sake ở sao
Ừ nếu mày Sake thì áp dụng cho Ờ
Ừ tôi không Nhớ xuất kia cụ thể là cái
gì
Anh thường này sắp cắt cho là sau khi
nghe tôi ghi lại nhầm đấy Sake à
Ừ anh em saka
Ả rập cắt này thì hợp nó nó nó là kiểu
dạng là kiểu những cái phím tắt để mình
có thể bấm nhanh là sử trong pashto mà
mình sẽ có phím tắt kiểu
ví dụ tôi thường hay bấm là kiểu
A Gọi dudley kết kể là ai nữa là Lập
anh gấp đôi cái dòng mà mình vừa mới gõ
là xử thế Đây là đôi khi là tôi muốn nói
cái gì đó tôi phải cô nghĩ cái từ tiếng
Việt dịch tiếng mấy ông đó là từ từ khóa
tiếng Anh nó dễ hơn Hãy giả sử cân xuống
đê từ đã ký kết này chẳng hạn đấy nó sắp
cho cắt tp-store này ạ
này nó sẽ có khi boss sắc cắt như thế
này ở mấy ông xem ngô mấy ông thấy ra
thử cái này nó quá dài Và thậm chế có
nhiều cái mà mình không dùng vào Vân
nhiều lắm cho cặp của một cái nó rất
nhiều và mình còn thể cấu hình được nữa
nên là cách phù hợp lý tưởng hơn đấy Đó
là mấy ông sẽ tra thêm khái niệm chí
Khiết Như này ra hai ở trong ngành ngày
này được đó là dùng thêm chi phí ship
như này hiểu nó sẽ ra dạng kiểu kiểu cái
bàn và tổng hợp những cái đơn giản ứng
dụng như thế này chứ ship từ chi TP này
thế này
chị sẽ ra một loạt như này cho bé uống
xem và đương nhiên là kèm theo kiểu ví
dụ trong bị ông xử thế
nhở nó bị trừu tượng hơn tôi thở để cụ
thể là leo nhé Mấy ông sẽ xem tôi đấy à
Tôi có cái Trang nhớ là có cái Trang à
Trang của tổng hợp toàn bộ những cái
của Leo hát
chứ không phải chai này không phải trả
lời
à mà trang khác cơ nhưng mà tôi quên
sướng ở nhatrang lại hai này cái này cho
anh chích hết này đây tức là sao nghĩa
là
3 cách gõ lệnh nó bê đầy đủ tất cả các
mọi lệnh của nó là chẳng hạn cái từ
vsport trở về dì Vân Thực ra cái này à
em gái tôi thấy lửa hai nửa giọt giờ ở
đây là ai đấy Bấm vào đây đọc tài liệu
này nhà cái vẫn có cái giỏ đó là cá nhân
tôi khi mà sự để hiểu được cái này thêm
thì đúng là phải lên cái trang api của
thằng ta lại đọc thêm tài liệu này trong
vải thô hơn tài liệu này mới tài liệu
đầy đủ nghĩa là ông có thể hoàn toàn này
gõ dụ à vai to make này
thế này à xe tải để nó sẽ ra cụ thể cái
hàm là chuyện cụ thể và những cái gì
Thậm chí mình phải đọc thêm mà xem là nó
Nó kiểu
Ừ nó xử lý như thế nào đến ngờ trong
trường hợp này có vẻ thời đang bị lỗi bị
ẩn này đi như có phải gái thì có đấy
Thằng này toàn là like 15 hay sai rồi
nhớ đấy thử Ví dụ như thế
ô ồ có điện cho toàn bộ code Akashi
cheetah một cái ra hai và ông hoàn toàn
thể áp dụng ví dụ là cái cái cây tôm có
nhá cả word đủ đủ mọi kiểu chi phí có
hết này
Kinh này
xe điều hướng này hạ thế
Ừ mai flash này
ở đó có rất nhiều
có ai để những từ khóa là mấy ông tra
Google à
Ừ thôi Bây giờ lại quay lại chữa nghỉ à
Từ từ tôi hôm nay tôi sẽ chữa là chữa từ
ạ nhóm thứ 16 nhé Ê mày Cả Nhóm kia thì
để hôm đứa 7 chữa tiếp tôi sẽ chữa nhóm
ví dụ miền Làm sao để chặn cái post đó
để chống Pháp
làm tôi nghĩa Có thể cậu cài đặt lại với
cái post đấy mà nhé
Anh đổi mật khẩu thôi còn nếu mà vẫn sợ
thì có thấy không thể gỡ được không phải
gỡ không thể gỡ cái đi được đâu
em xem cái ác
U16 này
đi khám
ghi tên value Air
a fluid balo thử nó không đúng nó làm
đâu
Anh hiểu rõ hàm trả về nó là đấy toàn bộ
các
a when i
a bit
bài hát
Ờ cà phê tôi trả thẳng ra ngoài đi
ừ ừ
vendo Nội
bài hát
à à
bài hát này tôi nhớ không lầm là
à à lớn hơn bạn lớn hơn ok
[âm nhạc]
ừ ừ
chữ thật
an ninh
anh
đúng không xuống dòng
cô gái khủng long này như thế này mà tôi
thích thì đôi khi kiểu Để như này nhưng
nó xuống dòng Nó dõi đấy nó sẽ mạch la
hơn này
hơn à
Ừ đấy toàn bộ size 11
Khi nào xong
anh không hiểu ông ấy làm lắm
Ừ cái này lên đội nón lá tết này à
ờ ờ
ta có
Có ai đi khắp này size bằng hai không
hiểu hai cái gì cũng chưa Tao bảo không
hiểu hay
em của ngày là cái gì không quy ước rồi
ngay
em
chuyển va lên nghe Nó hơi bị buồn cười
chuyên ba cho nó lên hơn cười cũng được
ngoài xử đi thế cái xe này ở đâu
best audio
Return value
Ừ cái này không cái sai này tên tên của
cái này nên chúng chung với tên này chứ
không phải cho ông ông truyền lên xuống
trả về nhé đặt tên buồn cười quá
xe tải cẩu chất tham này rồi time
bộ phim sex VIP không hiểu lắm đấy
time gọi điện O
ê ê
cho tôi bảo rồi Nếu về sau sợ vì sau sẽ
sửa mình đẩy nó xuống kiểu ngày mai sau
thích thì mình chỉ đắp w đây này ở nhà
nhanh Này Where in ID
anh không hiểu Dạo này lắm
lại có cả Phong Trần
Ừ thế thế nào nhỉ
đoạn mẹ đi này lần đầu tiên đâu phải
quay truyền được phong chân ở trong này
đấy nhưng mà When ID là đoạn này làm nhà
nghỉ à
anh đi nằm trong cái đúng rồi à
anh không hiểu đoạn này lắm
Có ai đi nằm trong danh sách shop Garena
thì ở đây đoạn này đang ông này làm là
dùng quay in Tôi thấy không hay lắm là
trò đến thằng
có hóa đơn kiểm tra là
thứ thứ
A gọi là cái này chính xác chính xác là
gì Cái này không phải là tên là chiếc
tham mà lấy toàn bộ thời gian mà cái
ngày ngày mà ngày ông ạ Ông cái chuyện
đưa và cười vậy bây ngày ngày mà người
đọc cho mình kiểm tra xem ngày hôm đấy
có những cái đơn nào đã duyệt hoặc à
ở cùng cái sân đấy ngoạn Lấy toàn bộ ra
lấy thì tha mở ra ở đây tôi nó sẽ làm
như kiểu như này sẽ là
a viết phương trình này nó sẽ là kiểu
Build đúng không
ở bưu đúng nhỉ
tham ở đây một bia chứ Một you
bưu thôi
Ừ đúng nhỉ một điều chứ làm sao
ngày hôm nay ngày hôm đấy phải toàn bộ
ra có thể nhiều view nếu trong ngày hôm
đấy rồi sao
này lắm Sẽ bạn đã tập bay của nhóm này
ở đâu sao
anh làm gì có thằng Sam nhỉ Cứ ngỡ mày
cái thằng tham cười quá anh hả
tình hình chưa sửa tôi kiểm tra của ông
kiểu gì niềm tin à
nhỉ Tại sao có tham ở đâu nhỉ não
lòng tham là gì em
Ừ vậy nha
khi bé Xuân Mai
anh hem Star Taemin lại không có phải
Tab nữa Chẳng hiệu điềm gì
Ừ tôi không hiểu được cái đoạn này làm
không Giờ cái này không giờ đúng không
chẳng cần một ai đi luôn này Đấy tiếp
theo thì một bưu thì chỉ có
à à đâu sao
A1
31 biêu có 10 giờ đúng ạ không Giờ thì
nhà thuốc nhiều bưu nhỏ
ca nhạc gà Nó vẫn thuộc nhiều bưu thôi
sẽ Return à
a di
ấy sẽ one-to-many này many-to-many này
A1
có một thằng ngày thuộc nhiều view
a1n
pin ra ngoài nhé
này có nhiều hot mini Đừng on how many
ok đấy
người làm tôi nản quá
thể hai thì sẽ dùng VSIP và đoạn này mà
bạn chất nó sắp vui nhưng mà không ai
làm kiểu như này là em ạ sẽ là
waste đây đúng không
đúng không
có thêm cột ID ở đây thì mình mới nối
được sang thằng đi rồi này that time i
đi
có ai
nó phải như thế này
à hài sôi ghép tour gì Tại sao tại là
phải tôi đây
các bạn chắc không cần tôi đâu
em cứ làm việc với collections hợp lý
hơn nó vẫn gọi được cái này nó vẫn được
nghe các bạn này làm gì
Ừ chắc cái gì anh không hiểu đoạn này
lắm
khi tham
anh không giai đoạn này nối nhau như này
chảy nghĩa gì cả ha
anh không hiểu đoạn này đâu Mày đang làm
gì vậy
chú truy tử tham
ex2 time start
ha ha Mày lấy tất cả không giờ
Giờ sao - cái khoảng thời gian như này
đúng không
Ồ vãi chưởng
nghệ à
que à Mẹ Đã dần hát ở đây là được
à Xong rồi à
Giờ ra ông trả về đúng mỗi này thôi cần
gì phải trả với nhiều chưa hiểu
ở đây ông trả về đúng kiểu
em lấy toàn bộ khung giờ miễn là không
nằm trong cái ngày ngày truyền vào và
sân đấy thế thôi
tạp đấy hả
30 năm trong cái khung giờ này bởi vì
cái yêu này chỉ có một khung giờ em à
nếu không nó làm nha em bưu chỉ 10 giờ
thôi thì lấy toàn bộ khung giờ nghĩa là
không giờ không nằm trong cái bia đấy ở
được đúng không
Ôi không dùng game Trần ship luôn dùng
cho dùng cái từ từ ư
anh
này dùng cho
anh không còn sẽ cho tụi chị lên vì sao
cố trong mày về sau tối ưu không không
tối ưu được đấy mệt
em chụp ảnh chữa ràng thì bây giờ lúc
làm thôi em đứng Xem đương nhiên à cho
lỏng rất là tốt Mình có ông về sau cũng
nên làm cho trộm cá thứ nhưng Cái quan
trọng là
xử lý bài toán ở đây đang chưa Đang chưa
ổn lắm không sao tôi đang chữa dần nó
uống thôi và anh chữ ở đây là kiểu để
tham khảo thôi chứ để vừa mới ông sửa
lại thì
sợ lại hết theo ý tôi thì cố Tại dùng Ai
mất mạng
dân dân thôi tra để nếu nhổ lịch nữa
không ạ là ngày 30 đó nha 33 mốt nghỉ
số 30 ngõ 50 mình sẽ bảo vệ thử để mà
xem à từng nhóm đang tiến trình nào gọi
là bảo vệ thử đây là những tính năng lớn
thôi ngoại
a57 mất tích rồi à
ở nhóm 19 à
hôm nay chưa có cái gì mấy này
anh tặng thì à ok
15 20 sản xuất Phương Trinh Tâm Nguyễn
Âm Nhạc
Ừ bắt cosmo này
anh cũng có sốt
anh sốt Huawei Watch
ở đây lấy ra tên Ok truyền ra bộ Doctor
chuyên gia cả à chuyên ngành không ạ
Ừ ok
hôm nay là tham Đắk Tô
ông vẫn còn chuyện đê Lên đây ăn sau
được truyền đi đây này nhé
Cơ Sở Truyền Kỳ vào đây hết time West
Ham là để lấy làm gì nhỉ
kết ham là để làm gì
Ở ngoài cao Tết
A A Apple
Ừ thì phải có những cái tên rất là lạ
khi sex
cho iOS Pearl cái gì nhỉ
our helper này là cái gì nhỉ
ừ ừ
à à
cài thêm cả cái thư viện này để làm gì
bí quyết Việt Nam anh vs
Em chưa không Giờ cũ một cái hay
Ừ chứ không giờ
Ừ ok ok
đấy do tôi nghĩa là một vài nhóm đang
làm tiến trình dạy ngay cần tôi chấm qua
hôm nay sẽ vi qua chứ kiểu này nó bị
thấy em mấy ông đang xử lý nó cũng tạm
phải toán đây này thì tôi giải quyết
được trong bể Ông nghĩ tôi nghĩ em với
ông sẽ nhẹ hơn chỗ nào
Ừ đúng rồi nhóm 20 năm 20 tím non thì
cho tôi chấm cho đang nhóm 21 đây ngắm
21 rồi
chả lên sự thành Đức Trường ơi à
cho kết hợp với mdtech về mà để mà kiểu
anh xem qua cốt của em cũng như
chấm luôn nhỉ
à à
[âm nhạc]
a mã gen để anh đi mất sao
muốn nhá các bạn sẽ tự nói ý tưởng thì
anh đỡ mất công hiểu đọc hiểu Xong rồi
anh chữa chữa luôn các bạn cốt luôn
chương trình máy các bạn nha thôi
là nước chấm chay ở đây vậy
I select Sao
dạo này không hiểu lắm
ở
siêu thị ngay cái đầu tiên ở thấy đoạn
này khó hiểu rồi
Ừ ok
Ừ cái này
Ừ mẹ dùng quýt à ok chi tiết a data thuê
bồ
ở nhà tôi vẫn không khuyến khích của cải
đạo Thay bồ lắm
bài hát tại sao cứ phải chọn xếp sao này
điểm gì vậy
I last saw track ID
a How to scandal
dùng mạng của đoạn này và
dùng snack về Axelo kiểu này
thằng
xe lách bình thường với ceclor em kể để
hôm sau ra kỹ hơn cho à
ở cái đoạn này là gì đấy lưu lại à Cái
điểm danh mà đúng không lưu lại
rồi tôi để mô nữa
cái nhóm này nhá
có kích thước nhỏ ma
từ năm 21 này nha
anh nói chạy My xin cái Thứ Tư đúng
không
Ừ hi vọng các bạn tạo sister để mà tôi
thử test thử xem nào ship đôi chỉ cần
sister mình cả lớp hoặc cà sinh viên
thôi
a How to scandal
Em rảnh chưa
anh
như đã hãy chọn buồn cười à
em chuyển năm tháng ngày
lên một lớp đúng không truyền à
không
môn thôi
ở lớp mình ơi đâu mày một lớp chỉ học
một môn rồi thì phải
Anh tên lại
lưu thứ ngày
Ừ vợ bao lỗi thì có mùi ông này làm đã
ta bây chúng ta tinh rồi
Anh vừa xong đấy
về mái trường
sáng
anh không ai lưu thứ à em ạ làm bắt đầu
cái sai đấy
i p IP sân à em gái xinh
à à
sex tube
nhóm 21
Ừ ừ không
weekday rồi để lấy được thứ từ cái biết
rồi không cần 10 tạo thế
mạch led class này Tại sao có 2 bảng A
U23 này
không đẩy lên chỗ này đâu nha
à à
ừ ừ
đấy hả
viên ở luôn
à à
em có last wish they wish they thêm st
đây không có ép này tại trường
Ừ chắc chắn không diệt zombie của ai
ạ
bây giờ này tôi có duyệt đâu
em tự nghĩ này ra không hề cho vụ Chắc
chắn là tôi không cho vụ thử luôn
em làm linh tinh rồi
không không không quan tâm cốt đấy
Ừ ông còn làm tạ đúng pha immolation về
chưa
ông muốn làm về à chú khóa biểu thì nó
sinh nó tự động sinh ra giống như là
điểm danh hết từng nói rồi chẳng qua là
chưa điểm cho anh thôi Mình sẽ lưu lại
bảo như vào điểm danh luôn Mình không
cần lại tạo mất công kiểu dạng như thế
này đâu
và đương nhiên là mình muốn lưu lại thứ
của lớp đấy sẽ học nhưng mà mình lưu
thẳng vào trong lớp là kiểu cách nhau
bởi dấu dấu phẩy là được rồi Hoặc là lâu
lại rạng reason lưu lại dạng mạch tùy sẽ
lưu lại vào một cột ở đây nữa là cột 1
cột là wish ray như thế chẳng hạn và lưu
lại kiểu cha họ reason tùy nó sẽ cả nhà
à à
I Miss Day hoặc à
cả ngày cho mình sẽ lưu lại cậu Vissan
ngại được anh em mình đi lại được là là
kiểu
dụng được sửa đất lập trình nhé
có một đi sẽ cậu lại lãng mạn ngay cho
mình sẽ đánh số Nó là kiểu à
một bắt đầu
số 1 là thứ hai hai cái gì đó mà
một lần thứ 2 chỗ ngồi 1
này từ rồi thứ sáu ra sự nha anh nhá là
sợ nhà nhé ông đưa lại di dân kiểu ngay
đúng không sau khi ông lấy ra ấy
mấy ông cái đoạn này
à à
ở đây đầu tiên là đây tôi lấy cái lớp
phải ra đúng không Lát này bằng class
Anh
tên class này
chạy lên pha rotor đi
à à
ở Zalo này
đã test chán thế mình sẽ có
nào có ghét này
2/21 vậy
từ ngày soạn trần với này
à à
thì tại sao để lỗi nhập
chị xem nhé
The Flash
em song ca kệ đi tại sao cái này không
nhận nhà cô chết 21
à à
cho anh em ạ
tai nghe cho ngành
à à
ở
khai báo nó là dạng này thì mình sẽ bảo
nó giả mạo trong này mình sẽ có cái cá
sợ đây
ở đây sẽ là vui
ở đây nè Nó sẽ làm đây hiểu nó lắm anh ạ
ở chung nhà ở đâu xinh chứ ạ
Âm Nhạc
a cat
So
sánh các
area quần nào
ừ ừ
mặt sau đó mình sẽ làm gì mình ông mới
làm tự động tạo lịch của nó đúng không ạ
lịch của nó thì đây sẽ thử tao cho anh
xem nhé ờ ờ
à à
cái chỗ ca học cố định trong một thứ và
Ừ nếu mà ông muốn làm theo kiểu dạng là
lớp đấy chưa học ca cố định và trong
những thứ cố định thì nó sẽ và toàn rất
là rẽ khởi nghĩa tôi sẽ làm thì cậu lại
đi sẽ lưu lại thêm một cái ca cố định ở
trong ngày nữa là được mình sẽ thêm một
cột nữa là cột ship và k
em hiểu ngay
từ lúc đầu trà sữa hay cái phép lui lúc
đầu mới tạo lớp mà Sử Ca Một thôi chẳng
hạn như thế này không ạ sau đó thì mình
à
mình xử lý nữa sao mình sẽ tạo mình sẽ
tạo gần như là thôi khỏi biểu cho nó
chính xác và mình tôi bảo tạo cái điểm
danh cho nó xong rồi mình chỉ là thêm
cái điều kiện là nó chưa được điểm danh
thì nó sẽ là thời khóa biểu thôi yêu
không nghĩa lịch học mà vẫn là những
ngày đấy nhưng chưa được điểm danh hiệu
không được học mà vẫn là ngày đấy mà ông
lưu lại thằng ở trong cái cái bảng điểm
danh này là được mà không
Anh sẽ cố định thế nhưng mà mặc định là
sẽ ở trong vòng à Từ giờ cho đến hết Cái
khóa đấy hết cái cái cái môn Thế cái môn
này cái sắp chết đi này Đấy cái môn này
thì mình sẽ ra thoát chết rồi em biết mà
nó không thì sẽ là kiểu
thì mình sẽ lấy ra được là có ngày bắt
đầu ngày kết thúc đúng chứ chính xác làm
thường à không nên là start và mdash
kiểu ngày mà toàn nó sẽ rất là khó
kìa bởi vì năm tự nhiên có một vài nơi
sẽ làm cái kiểu là ông thấy là rõ ràng
cho nó thời gian bắt đầu học ngày hôm
nay với kết thúc ngày hôm nay nhưng thực
tế nó là bao nhiêu buổi chính xác thế
Ừ cái này bao nhiêu tuổi mà không
thế lessons
khi nghe ông chỉ cần xóa hai cái đi ông
chỉ cần lấy cái số quan tâm ông này
xuống bao nhiêu buổi như thế này nó mới
chuẩn này chứ không phải là ông lấy 2
cột này còn này hay có sai rồi Chỉ cần
có tâm con này thôi là là là kiểu có bao
nhiêu buổi cái này thôi
em giả sử tôi có
môn là muốn P là sẽ bụng bao gồm 30 buổi
đi chẳng ngại đấy thì
tôi sẽ có
anh đừng có viết hoa nhé
cho hàm Thúy hoan ở đâu
thì mình sẽ có là
nhà thuốc môn học này
là
dòng tu rồi
Ừ lát nữa xong Em có biết cái này đâu
đấy
Ừ thì mình sẽ có cậu mình quýt theo cái
a stack
một ngày sẽ lấy được là có bao nhiêu
buổi nóng lạnh đấy rồi mình này đi nhé
Anh muốn đặt tên nó cái gì
Anh sắp chết cái thêm s em có chỗ ông
không thấy có chỗ thêm nét này
đi mua đồ không thể né đâu nha mua đồ
không thể máy đâu
có ai cả trường
à à
xe tải Ok sắp chết này nó sẽ ra được số
buổi không ạ ạ ạ
à à
Ý là mình chỉ việc đơn giản là mình sẽ
nhân nó lên nhân nó lên mình sẽ Kiều
Ừ Vậy thì đợi tí nhé
ý mình mặc định tự tại thì nên có một
ngày bắt đầu
đó chính xác là ngày bắt đầu của
Ừ nếu mà theo lớp như lại bắt đầu của
lớp đấy Ra thế thì sẽ rất là start date
của cái lớp đấy
em hát tốt nhạc cho ngày mình sẽ có
Tablet của lớp lại đi khi tắt bếp
sẽ có cái ở đây này à
Xin ngài cho gọi đến sau cho tôi thôi
là ngày hôm nay là xử thế
Nói như thế này sau đó thì tôi sẽ cộng
là tôi sẽ cộng thêm từng ngày rồi tôi
kiểm tra xem mà Thư đấy nó thỏa mãn hay
không đấy kiểu như thế
Ừ từ đây có thỏa mãn hay không và cậu
kia cứ mỗi khi thỏa mãn thì tôi sẽ tạo
một cái điểm danh cho nó ra đồng thời
lưu lại là đếm tăng và một cứ thế cho
khi tôi tạo đủ 30 30 buổi thì sẽ là 30
điểm danh bài toán sẽ nó sẽ là bằng 30
buổi
cháu có biểu đấy Đấy nó sẽ là như thế
này nhớ đương nhiên là đây các bạn chưa
tình những bài toán là nó vào ngày nghỉ
lễ 2 vào những cái ngày nghỉ gì đó Nhớ
về sau mình có thể xóa buổi đi mình à
mình có thể thêm những cái buổi ngày
nghỉ lễ vào giờ xử thế là sướng thế còn
bây giờ làm bài toán nó được bớt phức
tạp đi thì bỏ qua với cái vụ đấy được tế
về sau mà mẹ bỏ - những ngày nào để mình
sẽ loại trừ những ngày đấy nữa
ạ bây giờ nha đầu tiên thì tôi sẽ lấy ra
được là for đúng không
em không có bình tĩnh đó là của ai đúng
ở ngoài đây là sự qua đây Chu này
A và
đây cho bằng không này
à Xong rồi à
ô tô khi mình tạo xong thì biến nó sẽ
cộng cộng là sử thể
So sánh lấy ngày hôm nay ở đâu lấy lấy
cái ngày à ngày ta đến này
sẽ cát ở đây
ngày à
thì nó sẽ là một các bon
à mà thể mình có thể à Lấy luôn
mãi rồi
ạ
có gì nhé
à à
Xin chào luôn nè
Thì bây giờ mình sẽ
đấy Đúng hạ sẽ kiểm tra là ít
Zip đô la classe cho nên start date này
à à
anh như thế này sao tiếp theo là ít hết
mình sẽ kiểm tra xem mà nó nằm trong cái
thứ này không nó sẽ là các bon này à
I really
thì nó sẽ có kiểu
lấy which để kiểm tra thứ ấy sao mà
trước mắt tai rằng không biết có dao
thế thì
a men đây thì nó là một cơ sở sửa lại
nhé
đã sửa lại Nó là một này ba này vào năm
này đó à
a cho tôi lấy cái e chả thế
à à
Mở bài tôi thu zê zê ngày hè E là trong
đúng xem nhé
em gỡ xảy ra là 1
Âm Nhạc
vì nó không được
Có phải đây này
Anh nhớ chỉ cần gọi đến Hàm format thì
nghỉ
à à
có
ai chỉ còn gọi thì qua mát thôi pho mát
này e này
chú chạy này
ừ ừ
à à ừ ừ
à à
Em gọi đi show format đi
ISO format
3000 Tôi muốn nó ra cái thứ thứ như là
tôi phải làm cơ Nói show format nó ngoài
anh
cần sửa lại đây thôi
em sửa lại đâu nha
Ý là nếu mà nó nằm trong iniread
thế này nó
500ae y ngay
Ừ thôi đầu tiên tôi đến ở ngoài đi à
Ừ nếu nó nằm trong in Android Như Lai
ở thời tiết
ở nhóm 21 cho nhóm 21
A và
ở trong Clash with đây này đến cộng này
ờ ờ
A gọi đến sắp chết
ở nhà gọi đến
khi
cài đặt tên là gì nhỉ
khi stress sedalia classes assistant
Bộ tai nghe này
ở điểm này tăng tăng dần
ở đầu tiên thì
kiểm tra nó nằm trong cái này để em tăng
dần ok rồi này sau đó thì mình sẽ tạo
cái attendant cho cái lớp đấy thôi
Ừ đợi tí tôi sẽ tạo thành đình II
Âm Nhạc
à à
máy quét này à
chị sẽ à class cho Đéc Ok chuẩn luôn này
lát sẽ đi này sau đó đi sắp check ID
chẳng hạn thế
Có ai đi này
khi con gì cũng ah tại bảng ở thiên đình
mà còn gì nhỉ
scadal idea đấy thế này là thư ca không
cần phải Coast and scared i nữa chỉ cần
có
sắp chắc ai đi và và
mà sku
ở bãi bỏ qua những tờ đấy chỉ còn biết
xa bớt là gì và thế thôi thế thôi Chỉ
Cần Thế Thôi
biểu em nhưng mà em đang làm là nó bị
phức tạp quá và cái with date này wish
they này của em làm sai rồi cái nghĩa là
mày toán đơn giản thôi Làm cái của em nó
tách ra làm hai thế nó phù hợp cho việc
là một lớp Nó có thể là học hai ca cùng
một ngày còn bé anh làm anh cả rất đơn
giản là một lớp chỉ có nó cố định luôn
ca cố định luôn môn này cố định luôn
những cái này nó còn họp này ngon đấy
ngày bắt đầu là gì này sau đó thì điểm
danh sẽ chỉ ở điểm danh bắt đầu từ từ
ngày hôm đấy cho đến 30 đủ 30 buổi của
cái của cái môn Đấy thế là được rồi nó
sẽ đơn giản hơn nhiều
anh đã nói kiểu như này nó sẽ tạo ra nha
ở đây tôi các bạn Xóa ngay đi nha
anh sẽ có thêm 2 cột nữa là cột à
Anh sắp chết ID cột cột a
ờ ờ
Có ai đi
ở cột không có quần ID tự động tăng của
ông ạ
Ừ ông điểm danh nó sinh viên kiểu gì
10 điểm danh sinh viên
anh không định điểm danh sinh viên ở
ưu điểm danh theo lớp áo lớp ở nhà chưa
hiểu không ạ
không
ở những cái điểm danh nhà trẻ nghĩa thì
a nhớ thời khóa biểu rồi gọi điểm danh
cái gì
anh làm gì có khái niệm điểm danh lớp 7
giản thôi
thế này
rồi đi à tạm để luôn đi
a status
mà phải điểm anh nó sinh viên chứ không
phải điểm danh lớp đấy có học môn đấy
không à anh cũng chưa biết là em sẽ điểm
danh kiểu gì hả vào hôm nay lớp đấy có
dạy không hay như nào
em chưa hiểu lắm chưa hiểu cái điểm danh
Lớp của em à
Bây giờ ngoài đời em thấy điểm danh từ
lớp đấy và Mun đấy như thế nào
đó là lớp đấy Hôm nay có dạy không à
chẳng quan tâm là sinh viên học à anh
nhưng
Ừ anh không hiểu về tính năng này nó
ưu điểm danh ngài điểm này sinh viên hay
là điểm danh cho cho giáo viên để mà
chấm công và giáo viên hay như nào Mục
đích của cái điểm danh này là gì
lần này cái điểm danh này đúng không ạ
sau tất Thằng này không có đẹp đâu thì
cứ để xa tất ra xử mình sẽ cho xa tất là
không chẳng hạn làm chỉ là đây sẽ chỉ
đơn giản là có việc
giáo viên điểm danh sinh viên theo lớp +
ngôn Ok Thế cái bảng điểm danh chi tiết
bảng điểm danh sinh viên của em đâu
khi bạn làm sao làm được cái đấy khi mà
không có cột anh đi ở trong mà niệm danh
em nối sang tiếng Anh sinh viên cái gì
Ừ thì tao bây có phải sao bây giờ sai xử
rồi nữa
gì có thấy bạn những sinh viên nào đây
bảng bảng này là bạn à
có thời khóa biểu xong rồi bảng ngày mà
điểm danh của em á vãi chưởng
cái đi rồi Thành
a-class sẽ đi làm gì nhỉ
Mày xem xem lại bây nhóm của em
à Anh ơi con cá ảnh không nhỉ
có cái đa tao bay để mà nói xem đấy
về giá
Em có biết đây ở đây Ngoại trưởng
10 nghĩa tôi Duyệt quyetdaik luôn rồi
sang Nga
từ ngày mua này
từ người dùng này
cô sinh viên đúng không sinh viên là xu
thế sinh viên à
nhé và cái đầu tiên cầm sửa web thì
không ghi dấu kênh nhé
sinh viên này đúng không sinh viên này
sinh viên thuộc lớp nào này
có lớp nào học môn nào Okay này lớp có
thu khóa biểu như thế nào rồi
Ừ cái này là nên có một cột có đãi đi
này
ý em nói
Ừ đúng nhá ở đây ở đây
thế này Moon
Ừ cái nào cứ bị loạn xạ của gì
mà tại sao có cái ngày Môn
Ừ thứ học ở đây nhỉ
những thứ nào vào ngày nào
những
bài bài toán ở đây
học môn này nó cố định
vì nó có ông này đang muốn làm và cố
định
môn theo ngài các thứ trong các thứ Cụ
thể một thứ Cụ thể một thứ
A và ngày này tớ không biết ngày gì
em từng buổi à từng buổi học
mà lớp lại có sắp chết đi rồi
Ừ cái bạn này nó sẽ dễ bị sai kiểu nhỡ
đâu Cái này môn khác thứ khác
Ừ cái anh ở chưa sửa sửa lại
áo vl Tội chưa biết gửi tao bay của ông
sẽ như thế nào nữa
có ai Tôi chẳng hiểu chẳng hiểu được là
mấy ông đang làm gì luôn thật thế ông cứ
kiểu hứng lên cốt xong rồi bây cứ loạn
hết cả lên tôi Tôi không thể nhớ được
tất cả nhân đấy nhóm có thể tôi từng
chữa mấy ông như thế nào rồi nhưng mà
tôi không nhớ được thì mình cũng vậy tôi
xin hẹn một cái chứ Hai Bà Trưng
cho bé ông ấy biết được là mấy ông
mấy ông đang làm cái gì thì mới ông cũng
không ngon để mà tôi gọi tôi chưa biết
chữa nhà
Anh không biết là ý tưởng của ông ấy thế
nào luôn
muốn chữa
Ừ chiều nay ông ở sinh viên nữa tôi ở
trên trường mà ông nghe chửi liên tục
quấy chứ không phải là kiểu học con
nhưng lại như là không không nghe chửi
đâu
mai cho mấy ông ấy chứ trên trường tôi
không thì gửi không đúng chắc chắn nào
tôi sẽ
Anh khá bực mình về mấy cái vụ kiểu mấy
ông làm nó cứ chẳng theo một cái chuyên
nghiệp gì cả
chứ không phải cốt chuyên nghiệp hay
không mà làm việc giờ là hướng lên làm
đấy và
à mà Nó kiểu nó cứ kiểu Chẳng đâu vào
đâu đấy à
Ừ cái này ông đi làm ngoài đời ông sẽ
gặp
anh nói chung là tùy có sếp có sếp dễ
tính có sếp vì không bà Sếp Khi Sếp Khó
Tính thì xếp dễ kiểu đối việc có gì phạm
có rất nhiều
nói chung là đừng dùng ta thấy bồ là tôi
tôi thấy bắt đầu hơi sai thì dậy mà
không ra tao thấy bố với dậy cho mày
không biết qua thôi nếu áp dụng như hàng
nhiều quá mình
thế sao nó không dùng Về do chẳng ai
dùng đã ta thấy bồ để mà làm mấy cái này
cá cho dù à Nó có cái lợi nó có phân tra
này Iraq này cũng có tìm kiếm Ừ nhưng mà
chẳng hay dùng mấy đó vì thằng bạn lại
bồ này mấy ông chồng qua thì nó ngu mà
đúng không nhiều cái
mới tôi dậy mấy ông tôi hạn chế có dùng
di gì nữa đâu
cà phê nutty Zone cái này nếu mà Mấy ông
a cho cách lưu lại lắm tốt
kiểu trai cát fail đoạn này nó ổn hơn
nói chung nhà nhóm nào cần tôi chữa thì
tôi muốn nhóm đấy cần gọi tôi google mít
tôi xem qua Cốt và mới hiểu được luồng
làm việc của mấy ông ấy không phải tôi
ngồi đoán mày lắm
ở đây nó gợi ý ngày mấy ông thấy ngon
tỷ
lệ kèo ngày chai các kiểu nhà này sẽ cậu
fire fail này Đấy số 10 mình sẽ Return
đây nếu mà lỗi này và thành công như thế
này xin hơn nhiều nó sẽ xịn hơn nhiều so
với kiểu
ông dùng kiểu kiểm tra nhưng với rồi cái
Thường ơi kiểu này
em mặc định thành công ấy thất bại Cường
ngay
ông đánh vợ file failed của nhà chị này
nhà ông phải chai cáp nhé Nói phải trái
các không thì nó sẽ bắn lỗi lầm lỗi
người dùng không muốn nhìn 001 những
người dùng Nhìn mấy cái lỗi kiểu gì thế
tại sao mắc Cộng Một Mình
tăng à
này
Ừ
cái biến này có dùng đâu nhỉ Ông tạo
biến Này ra rồi có dùng mình không thì
tui
hả Đấy có dùng đã
có điều lại Map
a few xong lát cái này ra
em hẹn đấy ID
ừ ừ
cho tôi hình dung mà ông tạo cái ID mới
Có ai đi Ở đây làm gì có nhỉ
tao dùng chỗ nào
ở đây ông phải dùng di questa đi mà
không bị tôi đúng không nó phải như vậy
chứ
Ừ
ngày mới đúng chứ
bài hát đúng không
đi sai đúng không
anh em phải chuyển xuống cuối nhỉ Không
phải như thế này mình chứ
cái này truyền truyền thuyết vào đây
đúng không
ạ sau đó đi truyền như này đúng không
ở những chuyến thẳng này xong không
phải làm như này ông à
tự động tăng được mà
Ừ ông muốn xếp như thế mất công xếp hai
lần được xét và một lần xong rồi đấy ạ
ở đây gái đi lấy cái đi của cái thằng
này xong rồi lại nó kiểu như này
Ừ Ông Sếp như này xong flash này
thế này ạ sau đó thì ông lấy à Ghost cho
đến nay đi này
Ừ để lưu lại xong lại xếp nhưng phấn nữa
hỡi mất công làm như thế
làm như thế nó sẽ luôn chuẩn một cái đi
nó Ừ chán thế
Phòng như thế này Nó đã trả về được cái
đi đấy cũng sẽ gần như làm phẳng ngay
luôn được với lại nó sẽ nhằm như thế này
thôi và cái này nếu ở ông tốn công xử lý
như này thì rõ ràng
thì rõ ràng là khi mà
sau khi mà lưu di tinh
à bút cái gì
à à
Ừ ông ông tạo cái vần khi mà ông Khi mà
ông huyết tinh khi móng
lưu lại gần như thế ông lấy được ID mà
ông lấy được ID đấy sau đó là ông ông
đấy được cả cái sắp chắc Cá thứ cho ông
cách tạo cái đấy ở ngay cái bút Tôi sẽ
thử ví dụ nha
từ là quần áo
ừ ừ
hiện nay ông lấy cái à
ở đường lót cái này đúng không
những người bạn này đây đúng không
xe tải
đi Cởi được không
em thử xem nhá
anh sex Tết nhóm nào nhỉ
chỉ cách chỉnh cái A
Ừ thôi vợ
xe tải Đổi thử mộng cái tôi lên tắt nhé
à à
can show này
cho tôi Giả sử tôi có data bay ở bên A
a school Life
Vì sao
xem có cái này ít cột lại
có để ngủ rồi đi rồi xóa để tự động cho
này nhá á
anh đúng không xóa để tự động tăng nhé
cho mày ông quen được à sao để tự động
đăng ký nhỉ Ai đi để tự động tăng nhá
Tôi có bảo bây giờ đây đúng không ạ
ừ giờ này flash này
hôm nay đúng trước
a buddha này
nên mà nêm giả sử Lý tôi sẽ điên sẽ điền
email rồi này à
D3 còn có gì cần phải điện đã một lô tự
đi ăn rồi Còn này tự ông điên rồi đúng
với email không thôi chẳng nhận đúng
không là xử thế đúng không ạ
không
em giả sử tôi điền Company ID sẽ là
à à
0126 này
Anh ở khi tôi code bằng pass tôm cho
quen cốt bằng pp tôm Đợi tí thay đổi sắp
item bạn
Ừ nó vỡ ý Có thế chứ quen rồi
a Company này Bây giờ tôi sẽ lắp Nick
thằng Trường bút này mình sẽ có cái à
bắt chước như tôi vừa trị cho ông
Ừ đúng kiểu Nga
ở nhà mình sẽ nát Company đúng chết bên
erd đúng chứ
a what what mày này sẽ là nêm sử tôi
điện vào nêm chứ điểm nên của ôzôn
nghỉ sẽ thử biết được đúng không ạ
à à
ở Mỹ lâu nha
Kể trên lỗi sao sư mấy ngày đi
ở nhà văn báo lỗi gì nhỉ
d-expert
i-lax
à à
sợ shop kia nên nó lỗi tôi chạy nha
anh không hiểu luôn tại sao lại này lỗi
nhỉ
anh hay sao
này à
a new status
từ ngày tôi thử này xem
phần mềm of non-object
hai bát cái
a company
anh em
à hài á
em vẽ thằng này không đoán được ra
company
Ô thế mình sẽ
nghỉ trên Company ID vào
chị xem bd thằng mua đồ bộ lấy được gì
thì nó này à
di truyền email vào Company ID
à À rồi
Ý tôi nói tôi à
Em có
mấy đứa Company name này
Ừ nó lỗi
ở cách nhau rồi cách à
bởi dấu cách đúng không em nhé á
à à
anh không hiểu lắm
ở đó vẫn ra tên này à
Ừ ừ đúng ngay đi không Tao lấy ra được
ai đi đoạn này không ấy đã được vì nó
chưa Lưu lại
ừ nếu thế thì mình có thể chưa trò là
mình có thể Ok mình không để bắt được sự
kiện là khi tạo này mình thấy bắt sự
kiện và khi tạo xong là sếp Vậy cũng
được
Ừ không sao
lấy lại đây này
cho nó phép luôn
ca nhạc khi mà tạo xong rồi khi bao gồm
cả update và bao gồm cả khi xuất khi mà
tạo xong rồi thì mình sẽ lưu lại tên mới
của nó chuyển thêm vào để lấy lại tên
mới tôi sẽ chạy thử lại cho ông xem nhé
à à
luôn à
ạ bây giờ sai sai đây tí Đợi tí đợi tí
à à
thứ hai phải lưu phải gọi đến hàm xúc
thật nhỉ
A gọi ha sếp nhỉ
Vì sao Tại sao
[âm nhạc]
ông đi resnow
trống này nêm này là mình sẽ lưu lại lần
này
Mà tại sao nó không lưu vào nhỉ
các loại test rồi nên mình không truyền
vào luôn nên có đây mình
anh không truyền thẳng vào nhỉ
đúng rồi tôi thấy có lưu lại that
thế nhưng có vẻ nên nó không chuyển vào
nhà test xong rồi lấy ra gọi hàm xếp nữa
lưu lạ
Âm Nhạc
ý nghĩa đang chạy vòng lọc khuẩn
Em dạo này
vì vậy hàm xếp nó lại chạy ấy là sếp nó
cứ thể nó xếp nữa chết rồi sao à
[âm nhạc]
sau khi mà mình đi lại mình sẽ lấy ra để
mình lưu lại phát nữa
anh nghe được
nữa sẽ làm kiểu nông dân kiểu này đi Vậy
à
à à
a cho đúng phải làm chuyện nông dân cần
này
chị sẽ
à quên sao ai đi chứ
Xin chào mất liên tục qua gọi vòng lọc
gọi
cái này sẽ là lấy lệnh hillcrest này
xong thì mình lấy cái ID ra mình lót
thêm vào
a cho mình lấy ID mình truyền vào để xếp
Vì vậy tôi định thủy cho mấy ông cái trò
là kiểu mình bao gồm cả update update
thì mình đôi khi mình cũng muốn lấy ra
chứ không phải mỗi led như thế này nhưng
có vẻ không được
Ừ nếu mà chạy cho hàm xếp ngay nó lại
can thiệp sâu và á Nó bị vòng lặp đi Xếp
này
a a đến thế tôi chơi trò này tôi chơi
trò này
Anh Nhớ có hàng mà sếp week dao
I
walk down
a file cái gì đấy
chị sẽ quay Ly
thì nó sẽ không bắt là nó không bán cái
sự kiện lên được
nghe được loa này được luôn à
anh có Ok chưa
hồ bơi vừa nãy chạy hàm xếp như này thì
nó lại lại gọi lại em chính ngân hàng
này bắt nó sẽ khởi tạo cái sự kiện là
đang xếp mà còn nếu mà sếp quay đi này
thì nó sẽ không khởi tạo sự kiện xếp nữa
và mình hoàn toàn để lưu lại thế này
hoàn toàn phù hợp với việc là khi ông
Chris và khi hoa khi ông update thì nó
sẽ update ở đây là bao gồm mới việc là
ông không lần trước là tôi không biết
tôi nói Ông chưa Nếu vợ ông Nếu mà gọi
tắt bếp kiểu như này
và những gói update kiểu này nha nó sẽ
không bắn sự kiện
anh Bởi vì nó không khởi tạo đối tượng à
cái cái Hà mất bếp này nó hơi bị dị ở
điểm là update này sẽ là của quay
builder chứ không phải là của em là quần
nên nó sẽ không bán những cái sự kiện
của Lê quân ông muốn làm
ông muốn làm cái kiểu update thì ông chỉ
có thể làm theo kiểu như này ông sẽ chỉ
có thể là ông phải khởi tạo đối tượng
này trông gọi hàm sếp cũng giống như
thằng class này tôi Tôi thấy cách tốt
nhất của mấy ông là thì nên à để nói
luôn chắc chắn nó luôn khởi tạo đối
tượng kiểu ngay khi mà ông già sự là đây
ông sẽ có đây
ở đài tiểu kiểu này kiểu kiểu như thế
này ông khởi tạo đối tượng
khi khởi tạo đối tượng 1 và ông file như
thế này sông lưu lại như thế này thì nó
bầu mập bếp này hoặc ở ông Ngưu
Anh ngủ giờ này
em ạ thì nó sẽ và ông gọi hàm xếp nhà
thì nó viết đấy chị ạ
Ừ ông pha như này thì bao đôi khi không
phải là file mà ông sẽ kiểu dạng word
nhé xuống Phước đi Ở nhà chẳng ăn cho
ông phốt nha ông sẽ khởi tạo đối tượng A
không đúng là nó khởi tạo đối D1 đối
tượng cho ông gọi hàm xếp thì nó mới
chạy vào cái sự kiện là xếp ngay nhá Còn
nếu mà ông khoe như này
đi soi ông chạy update luôn như hành hạ
nha
không bán cái sự kiện xếp ông sẽ không
chạy vào được trong ngày đâu để cách làm
nó hơi bị lằng nhằng rural cơ hội đầu
mới học thì công nhận là đoạn này rất
khó hiểu đề ông sẽ không phân biệt được
là lúc nào nó là quay budo vào lúc nào
là quần
ở chỗ thằng thằng này mình vẫn đang gọi
đến đây là quần không ạ nhưng mà ông gọi
kiểu này là gọi quay video rồi chị ạ
À nhầm đúng không
Anh đang chữa giờ Nhóm kia nhưng mà mày
chỉ mấy chữ A cho bé uống quá nó bị loạn
hết cả lên rồi đại khái Thế có nghĩa là
cái đoạn đấy ông ấy làm nó bị phức tạp ở
cái đoạn là xử lý này rõ ràng là bài
toán là hãy nên nhớ là controller xử lý
nít hôi những cái sự kiện bắt thì nên
nằm trong thằng mô đồ chứ không phải là
nằm nằm trong controller đi tôi như thế
ở loạt ra này
Ừ ok mát này
à 24 này
hai mươi tư
a fine with all là gì
à à
Ừ
mẹ trưởng Wiko
ở đây hết toàn bộ thông tin luôn ạ
a location
White ngoài làm gì mà ghê đấy
với City ơi sắp đi chí này cũng nhiều
đây
trong B cũng được em ạ
em không cần phải
khi trở về cụ thể như này lắm đâu
có sẵn
controller trở đi gần như vậy Sao mình
không sửa xóa gì vị trí mấy cái City
Hello cái Trần này đâu
Dạo này thì lòng theo cầu à à
Ừ thì tôi là lòng heo như thế này à
[âm nhạc]
ở cục nó thành một câu
trò
chơi hiểu amin của Ông cần gì phải chính
trị toàn bộ tất cả cái này
Em dậy chưa
I listen
business
em khó hiểu lắm
đấy là rất hết ở trong đây là Quân
ở bên container hiện thì ít cũng được
khi sex
càng cái đoạn này ở
cho nên nên tạm một cái hàm riêng cho bé
hàm này
số tiền một là ông nhảy Ông Táo hẳn Phai
riêng xử lý hay ông đoạn này ông nên a
thấy có đại là tại đúng không
ra à Nó khác nhau Chỉ có mỗi cái cả hai
đúng không Cũng như là
cái tham số truyền vào cái thứ thứ thế
thử tách ông nhá á
tôi sẽ thử làm cho ông ví dụ đoạn này
nha
à à
ừ ừ
bí quyết em đã sai đi
à Thằng là
anh ta của ông thì là không à
Đợi thì đợi tí
3 một cái nữa sẽ là
a website ID
à à
sestak ngon bằng nucelle
à à Xem phim sec ý chính chính nó mà ở
à à
thế này
a tells of Jack
wilshere được à
nhà xe
Tân An
Bộ tai nghe này
i as request truyền sang
phải này rồi gọi Avatar
Ừ đúng
các bạn này hình nhờ mấy ông nó bị làm
mà
Ừ ok ok
này nó sẽ như thế này nhá phibang
Anh đi quét
gọi được cho anh nhé ghét hay này
Lý Hải
I find a
a Store app
a a mini giá
cô đơn vị này đi à à
à à
anh em có say
không
dám dám không đợi tí amina đi này sẽ gọi
bên file này anh hay xuân này
Ừ nếu không Đây voi không trả về cái gì
đi mình sẽ có
amin cho đến
hai sẽ băng hợp check trả đến ai đi đó
Thứ hai này tôi sẽ truyền vào nó sẽ là
như thế này
chị sẽ là
a mắt này
ừ ừ
Hàm flash này
ở xã stack
Ừ cái này à
à Tôi đang định cậu truyền cái này vào
gì à Nếu không thấy à cái đoạn này sẽ là
hai nhà luôn này
nhưng mà cái file của ông ấy đang đến
như này nên thành ra là
trà xanh Nhã để sang Nga
chuyển vào nó là
Là Số 1 mất rồi
Ừ đúng
khi
mình chuyển vào đây số 1 mất rồi
Ừ mình không phải truyền vào là sheet
Ê khoan Mình muốn lấy cái shit One thì
bạn chất là cái này sẽ cần lấy á
ờ ờ
khi xịt khoáng ở
Ừ lúc thì nó ship ăn kiểu ngày được ngọn
đốt thì nó kiểu như 2
khăn cả nghe đi
sông ấy đến đoạn này hay này sẽ phải sửa
lại Nó sẽ là
ừ ừ
à à
em hết à
a z aloo
ngày và lái xe Dream
a two people
ông truyền kiểu đúng kiểu nhà được và
gán cho nó xong
chị sẽ có ship US này Spark ngay
A và Avatar nữa không ạ
à à
anh em ta nữa
Ừ Ok chứ
Ê đã xóa được khá nhiều cốt của ông ở đó
Ngon cái lô cái sân này nữa Tống của chỗ
khác bởi vì sao bên này bên xử lý ăn Min
Thì ông nên chỉ xử lý amin ở câu lại
thôi bưu nghiện những cái Hàn liên quan
đến những thằng khác nên Tống ở lâu quần
của nó
cho nên tấm mua đồ của nó không xử lý ở
trong này để ông ạ Ông ông hiểu cho làm
đã đấy nên sẽ cách kiểu khác
một cái nữa mấy ông có thể thể hơn mới
đó là tôi dùng cái dấu và nhé rối và này
dán con chó con chó thằng này Đây là sao
Có việc bởi vì tôi muốn gán vào thẳng
biến ăn mi này cái thai này mình truyền
cái ID cho nó ngoác đó mình sẽ chuyển đã
thế mình còn truyền cho nó là à Cái đôla
thay cơm chứ không phải Thay tất là sao
nghĩa là trong trường hợp mình muốn
truyền xít khoan vào cho nó hiểu dạng
ngay đâu mình sẽ truyền được mình sẽ
truyền thông qua đây này sau mình đầy ID
của cái file đấy mình truyền vào như này
xong rồi Cái biến này nó sẽ được nó sẽ
được Kiểu khi Ừ cái hàm số khi mà truyền
trong cái này nó sẽ được ghi thêm cái
chiffon để kiểu như thế
mã số để lấy cho ông avatar anh chơi nha
nói như kiểu ngay luôn này
Có ai có avatar đúng không bộ son môi có
ship Phen này
Ừ
tao ta đây I span span span span
xong rồi lưu lại Ok chưa
thôi là khó khăn là chỉ đơn giản đây nó
Nó là kiểu mình mình tống nó sang một
hướng khác kiểu như anh đừng có xử lý
bởi vì Cốt nó là việc lại đúng không ạ a
đây đổi cái này lại nữa nó là cho thai
nữa
xe
tải sẽ nối nhau kiểu nha Ok chưa
mình sẽ truyền truyền truyền dữ liệu cả
ngày
Ừ ông ấy cũng biết làm cho nó sần nữa
đâu rồi
ông nạp Điệp lại nó sẽ kiểu làm việc lại
những cái cậu cuồn cuộn như thế thì thực
tế là cái đoạn này mình nên làm kiểu kia
thậm chí ạ Thậm chí cái đoạn khuôn này
nó vẫn lặp lại của khí ở dưới này cũng
gặp thực ra ông còn thích thì ông thể
Tống cậu khác nữa tùy yêu rất nhiều cách
cả ở đây là xóa xóa bit Scenery nữa là
ổn nhà thực tế không nên xóa không nên
xóa gì cả nhà thôi Không làm được tùy
rồi tôi không cần tích làm xóa đi
khi cây tôi chỉ qua thôi Còn nếu mấy ông
à Muốn chữ cụ thể hơn thì ạ
Anh tính sau nha hôm nay
Ê mày gần hai tiếng rồi vẫn chưa chấm
hết được
Ừ chắc là có khi để Thứ Bảy đi Thứ bảy
tôi chấm nốt cho mấy ông có nghĩa hôm
nay mấy ông quá tải Mà tôi cũng
anh cũng buồn hơi buồn bởi vì à những
nhóm Nói chung là những nhóm
ở những nhóm mà không làm thì con nó còn
gì như những nhóm làm thì tôi thấy đều
đều có tư duy đều ổn nhưng mà
Ừ nhưng mà vẫn còn đang bị cậu
không ạ Tôi dùng từ không chuyên nghiệp
thôi chứ Cốt các bạn thì ạ Các bạn mới
các bạn mới tôi không để ép các bạn
thành giỏi luôn được tao Federer không
thể biến Sino được tao không thì vọng
rồi đấy Nhưng ý tôi là làm mọi thứ thì
Em làm từng bước từng bước nó phải rất à
Ôi da chậm Nhưng chắc đi và
và không và tôi tôi thấy mấy ông hỏi tôi
thực ra Vẫn còn hơi ít mấy ông vẫn đang
hơi ngại hỏi mấy ông vẫn tự mò mò là
nhiều
em lấy nửa tốt nữa xấu
Anh tốt là ám chỉ ông tự thân vận động
xấu ở đây là ông làm khi máu làm sai quá
nó đi con đường rất là xa giống như vừa
nãy bảo size.ao bệnh nó đi rất là xa lúc
đấy tôi
Ừ tôi sẽ vừa ngại sửa cho mấy ông vừa
nghĩa là béo cũng ngại sửa mấy ông sẽ dễ
bị nạn khi mà không làm sai rồi Bơ tôi
bắt ông đập đi xe lại ông có làm không
đúng ạ Mấy ông đã bị thế đó là mấy ông
đang đang Cốt nó bị cậu vẫn còn chưa
quen Đấy thế là mấy ông bác bộ cần phải
hỏi không thì tôi bảo ông đã đi xem lại
mấy ông sẽ lười không muốn làm thì ông
sẽ nạ nóng
cho chị cái đấy tự với ông hại mới ông
thôi đúng ạ ạ
ca nhạc hướng dẫn mấy vụ đó nha
đại học chính quy các thầy sẽ Kệ ông
ngoại còn học nghề thì người ta mà người
ta mà kiểu Thứa nói thảm thì cuộc đời
này nó thế người nào mà càng chửi ông
càng của mắng mỏ ông vân vân người ta
mới là người đang Thực sự để tâm mà ông
và quý ông không ạ bảo cậu thực sự quan
tâm
người nào mà kệ ông là kệ hạt mọi người
khen đểu ông ấy Vân ông sẽ không biết
được mình đang như thế nào ở đâu ạ tôi
tôi bực mấy ông Bực thật Ừ thì tất cả
chỉ là tôi vẫn còn đang giờ còn để ý ông
chứ hỏi kệ
mày cốt cái cột nhà kệ không có tâm thế
à Thế thì nói tại quán ông ạ tôi không
như thế đi làm mấy ông cũng phải làm
quen với việc à phải giống như tôi rồi
đấy tôi hồi đấy Công nhận mặt đưa nhà
khi bị thầy máng cũng có tự ai cũng buồn
buồn khi mình không làm được đồng ý thầy
nhưng mà cũng phải mà hơi trông Tí và
biết được là thầy đang mắng tốt vì mình
anh kể cả có lúc màng size có nhá Lúc
tôi có lúc những cái lúc mà
tôi bị mà ngoan có
Ừ tôi cũng khó chịu ở mức lắm nhưng mà
Ừ nhưng mà thực sự thì những người đấy
Mình lớn lên mới biết được là họ vì mình
được ạ nên mày Ông đừng có tự ái khi mà
tôi
Ừ tôi sẽ có lúc tôi sẽ cắt về mấy ông
phải gặp bởi vì rồi ra ngoài đời
có một lá xếp đã gặp phải ông Hải sẽ Kệ
ông luôn
Tùy ông Trọng không ạ
Ừ thôi bố mày tạo người thế Ờ chắc chắn
à
Có vài nhóm Hôm sau bắt buộc cần phải
chữa đấy ông ạ
Anh không muốn bị mắng Bị mắn thì ông
lên làm sếp thì lúc đấy thì trắng mình
ông thương ông chẳng ai thương hộ ông cả
ông làm không tự chịu Thế thì chẳng ai
màng Ông ấy ông là ông tự chịu
anh nha
à à